[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce 78 sport
spécial Jeux Olympiques le compte à
robourg est lancé à plus de 300 jours
desg tout de suite le
sommaire cyclisme sur piste l'équipe de
France aura l'étiquette de favorite
l'été prochain au Brésil nous recevrons
dans ce magazine Michel d'méda médaille
d'argent 2012 de la vitesse par équipe à
Londres et Grégory boget quadruple
champion du monde de vitesse
individuelle et triple médaille d'argent
Jo tennis en sport Laurent bolittin
Johan killou vise une première
participation au jeux paralmpique en
2016 actuellement 7e Français au
classement il devra rentrer dans le top
5 pour être qualifié portrait à suivre
dans cette édition golf j'ai testé cette
discipline qui sera réintégrée au jeu
l'année prochaine après avoir été
retirée du programme en 1904 le Golf
National de 50 ans nevi nous a ouvert
ses portes pour une séance
d'entraînement et puis en fin d'émission
coup de projecteur sur les sportifs vois
qui pourrait s'envoler pour Rio l'année
prochaine nous sommes actuellement au
Vélodrome de 5ant an en Yveline une
structure qui pourra accueillir les Jos
2024 si la France est retenue une
structure également où s'entraîne Michel
d'meda vicechampion olympique en 2012 à
Londres bonsoir Michel bonsoir alors
cette structure c'est vraiment une
structure idéale pour vous pour vous
entraîner oui bien sûr c'est un c'est un
excellent Vélodrome il est dit que c'est
le plus beau du monde donc voilà moi
j'ai j'ai pas un avis objectif bien
entendu parce que ici c'est c'est la
maison c'est là où je passe la majeure
partie de mon temps pour m'entraîner
donc les Joos sont dans environ 300
jours comment vous sentez-vous à 300
jours de C j très très bien le physique
va bien le moral aussi pas de bobo voilà
on est on est dans dans le droit chemin
pour l'entraînement et la préparation
justement la préparation on va on va en
parler ça va être quoi ça va être de la
musculation des
compétitions beaucoup de compétitions ça
va être on va dire comme d'habitude vous
avez pas changé grand chose oui ça va
être comme d'habitude on va on va y
ajouter des des petites particularités
justement en vue de cette année cette
année olympique donc bien entendu c'est
c'est de l'entraînement il y a pas de
secret composé essentiellement de
musculation de route très peu mais et
beaucoup de cyclismees Surp bien entendu
et oui dans la préparation il y aura des
compéti
moins que les années précédentes mais en
aura donc les JO ça représente quoi pour
toi bah les JO c'est pour moi en tant
qu'athlète c'est c'est le SOMUM c'est
c'est le maximum le niveau le plus élevé
c'est c'est la compétition la plus
importante d'une carrière parce que déjà
faire les jeux une fois c'est pas donné
les faire plusieurs fois encore moins et
être médaillé c'est encore encore moins
donné donc voilà moi j'ai j'ai déjà eu
cette chance d'avoir participé à au
olympique de Londres je suis reparti de
là-bas avec une médaille donc voilà
maintenant mon mon objectif euh
prioritaire et unique c'est c'est
d'avoir le plus précieux des métals à
donc cette fois-ci voilà exactement et
c'est une date vraiment que tu as coché
dès que tu as fini Londres tu as coché
cette date pour te dire je serai présent
à ce rendez-vous-là voilà exactement
c'est je vais pas dire au lendemain mais
presque de Londres voilà c'était c'était
Rio quoi tout simplement ce qui se passe
avant est bien peut être intéressant
mais n'a pas l'importance des Jeux
Olympiques donc pour moi au lendemain de
Londres voilà c'est c'est Rio et puis là
on y est déjà et la France dans ces JO
tu vois c'est une nation favorite
vraiment de ces Jeux Olympiques oui bien
sûr l'équipe de France en tout cas pour
le sprint masculin on va pas on va pas
se mentir et ni faire les les modestes
voilà cha français il va avec le
potentiel de de gagner donc pour gagner
sans on va pas faire de la fausse
modestie bien sûr qu'on est favori mais
on n'est pas on n'est pas ultra favori
on n'est pas plus favori que d'autres
d'autres nations donc voilà faut faut
rester concentré sur nous mais bien
entendu qu'on est favoris oui vous
comptez surfer peut-être sur la
dynamique des championnats du monde qui
se sont déroulé ici à 50 an en ibline
vraiment avec ces cinq médailles d'or
c'est 7p médailles en tout est-ce que
c'est là-dessus que vous voulez
construire le succès de des Jos de du
Brésil non en ce qui me concerne non je
pense pas c'était c'était un très bon
moment même un moment magique hein de
d'avoir autant de de réussite et de
titres ici à domicile mais non les Jeux
Olympiques ça se construit pas pas au
championnat du ça se construit pas 18
mois avant donc non bien sûr surfer non
plus mais bon c'est sûr que ça ça met ça
ça remet une certaine dynamique une
bonne dynamique puisque ça s'est très
bien passé donc il faut en profiter
mais pas non plus surfé après on joue
avec les mots mais faut pas s'arrêter
là-dessus parce que chaque compétition
est différent et les Jeux Olympiques
c'est encore différent et à mon avis ce
serait une grosse erreur de de chercher
à reproduire ce qui s'est passé ici aux
Jeux olympiques et donc pour vous ça
sera l'or quoi qu'il arrive ah non ça
sera je je sais pas en tout cas moi ma
préparation depuis tout votre objectif
c'est ça voilà mon objectif ma
préparation depuis le lendemain de de
Londres est basé uniquement là-dessus je
je suis pas dans je suis pas dans la
recherche de qualification aux Jeux
olympiques ou autre moi je mon projet et
bien sûr le titre olympique et pourquoi
pas pouvoir s'arrêter derrière ça donc
voilà mon projet est clairement le le
titre olympique la médaille
d'or je travaille pour ça je me donne
les moyens pour ça donc donc voilà
maintenant je ne sais pas ce qu'il en
sera mais en tout cas je mets je mets
toutes les chances de mon côté pour pour
obtenir ce ce que je veux merci Michel
d'almeda j'espère que vous rapporterez
des médailles dor dans vos bagages de
retour de Rio bien sûr place maintenant
à Grégory
Boger après Michel dalméda nous recevons
sur ce plateau Grégory boget bonsoir
Grégory bonsoir alors je vais rappeler
brièvement votre palmarès vous êtes CIN
fois champion du monde de vitesse par
équipe quatre fois champion du monde de
vitesse individuelle et triple médaille
d'argent au jeu on voit qu'il vous
manque une médaille aux Jeux Olympiques
c'est l'or justement c'est votre
objectif à l'année prochaine c'est c'est
l'objectif don athlète d'être champion
olympique en tout cas pour un sportif de
très haut niveau euh je l'ai tenté en
2008 par
équipe on a échoué à deuxème marche en
2012 en individuel et par équipe pareil
2è et puis bah je pense qu'on va
rectifier le tir et que je vais
rectifier le tir en individuel pour les
jeux de jeux de Rio donc pour vous ça
sera que l'or l' c'est toute façon à
chaque fois c'est c'est que la victoire
donc les jeux pour quand tu gagnes c'est
c'est leur olympique donc voilà c'est
ouais ça a toujours été ma ma motivation
d'être le meilleur de de de tout gagner
donc ça va être l'or encore une fois
quoi je vais partir pour aller chercher
l'or avec mes camarades en vitesse par
équipe et en individuel ça a toujours
été peut-être un regret pour l'instant
dans votre carrière de pas avir l'or
c'est c'est ça qui vous pousse justement
à vous dépasser à continuer à vous
entraîner chaque jour à vous à vous oui
bien sûr don à fond à chaque fois c'est
devenir champion olympique c'est un
objectif de carrière comme c'était le
cas pour devenir enfin d'être champion
du monde donc il y a une case qui n'est
pas cochée donc voilà c'est ce qui me
pousse les matin à me lever alors que
j'aimerais bien rester au lit à me
surpasser à
l'entraînement c'est vrai que chez nous
en France on a un très fort potentiel
donc aussi c'est ce qui me pousse à ne
pas fablir face à mes camarades et
coéquipiers de l'équipe de France et
justement est comment cette ambiance
dans cette équipe de France
on peut voir qu' cette ambi ambiance euh
on va dire ça l'ambiance a été meilleure
bien meilleure depuis l'arrivée de l'UR
gagné qui est arrivé en octobre 2014
donc on a vu les résultats que ça a
donné déjà sur les les championnats du
monde au mois de février à Saint-Quentin
à domicile au niveau de l'équipe
masculine de sprint on a tout raflé ce
qui a ce qui a jamais été réalisé
auparavant et puis non bah l'ambiance
est bonne après ça être encore peut-être
plus tendu plus de pression pour chacun
des cours puisque les Jeux Olympiques
tout le monde veut sa place et et c'est
pas tout le monde qui va pouvoir
participer aux épreuves olympiques et
justement vous êtes plutôt une bande
d'amis une bande de potes ou vous êtes
peut-être il y a des rivalités mais des
rivalités positives qui vous poussent
justement à vous dépasser non je dir je
pense par exemple à votre rivalité
peut-être avec un François Pervis par
exemple on pas on n pas des c'est pas
une bande d'amis c'est pas un groupe
d'amis
euh mais euh perform ça sûr mais ce qui
a fait notre force ce qui fait notre
force en équipe de France c'est qu'on a
ouais on a un très fort
potentiel on est surtous les podium de
du du sprint donc on se côtoit chaque
jour à l'entraînement donc tout le monde
veut montrer qu'il est le meilleur c'est
ce qui nous aide à se surpasser et je
pense que c'est cette force là ce qui a
ce qui a fait la réussite de la France
il y a quelques années à l'époque des
des Florent Rousseau Leurent Gané à r
tournant c'est ce qui fait notre
réussite aussi là après il faut que faut
que ça soit une rivalité saine euh c'est
ça pas ça pas toujours été le cas c'est
on va dire dans dans les deux dernières
années mais comme je dis depuis que
depuis l'arrivée de Laurent Gané euh
l'ambiance est bien meilleur et je pense
que oui il arrivé la rivalité saine
après de toute façon chaque athlète bah
c'est ce qu'il a à faire je pense en
tout cas pour ma part moi je vais être
champion olympique et je sais que c'est
en me donnant à fond aux entraînements
euh ça va me permettre de de progresser
et d'aider aussi mes mes collègues qui
qui sont un ton en dessous de moi pour
pouvoir me battre donc c'est gagnant
gagnant à tous les niveaux et quels sont
vos principaux adversaires pour ces Jeux
Olympiques si vous deviez en donner je
sais pas trois par exemple mon
principaux adversairire euh je regarde
pas j'aime dire que c'est c'est moi mon
propre adversaire après je pense que
tout le monde va vouloir donner le me de
soi-même
euh adversaire on parle des Anglais des
Australiens des
allemand euh il un Colombien qui qui qui
marche très bien qui a fait des belles
performances ces dernières années aussi
donc je sais pas en tout cas je me
focalise pas je me focalise sur personne
ESS de rester concentré sur moi-même et
puis si on se souvient des des propos
que j'ai pu tenir ou ou même un de mes
collègues Michel d'almeda les jeux
olympiqu
c'est c'est la guerre quoi c'est la
guerre donc euh toi en tant que soldat
tout seul tu peux rien faire donc il
faut que tout toute une armée soit avec
avec les soldats donne les les
meilleures armes pour pouvoir se battre
mais bon encore une fois je vais rester
concentré sur moi-même et puis euh
donner le maximum jgie qui et les
championnats du monde qui ét organisé
ici à 5ant an yvine qui ont été un
triomphe on va dire avec cinq médailles
d'or notamment pour la pour la France
est-ce que ça a aidé justement à
préparer c'est ces Jeux Olympiques oui
je pense que c'est un bon point de
départ comme je dis encore une fois
depuis l'arrivée de l' Gané il y a une
autre
atmosphère il nous a fait part de ses
connaissances et justement on a vu les
résultats que ça ça a donné sur sur les
championnat du monde donc c'est sûr que
en tout cas pour ma part moi ça m'aide à
avoir une vision plus plus claire
jusqu'au olympique après tout n'est pas
fini hein il y a encore du boulot
énormément de boulot mais bon oui oui
moi je pense que on peut aborder les les
Jeux Olympiques sereinement mais faire
les choses bien bien carré et que tout
le monde avance dans le même sens et
c'est vous qui avez poussé un petit peu
les instances françaises à organiser ces
ces championnats du monde juste avant
les Jos pour vous puissiez vous vous
entraîner je sais pas pour d'autres en
tout cas moi j'ai essayé de j'ai essayé
de faire prendre conscience à notre
président que avec un outil comme l'on a
en France
depuis
2014 une enceinte comme celle-ci mérite
d'avoir un championnat du monde et et
surtout avant les Jeux Olympiques comme
je dis il y a une stratégie aussi à
avoir et et c'est bien d'avoir eu ces
championnat du monde chez nous à la
maison les étrangers je pense qu'il
s'attendaient pas à ces résultats de
notre part on a compris pour vous ça
sera alors avant tout c'est ça ah pour
moi c'est ce que j'essaie de enfin je
pense que c'est ce que je transpire
voilà j'ai j'ai un de mes mes amis et et
collègues de l'équipe de France Michel
dalmeda qui qui qui a le même point de
vue que moi euh j'espère que oui moi je
parle de des collègues de l'équipe de
France mais j'espère que tous les
Français aussi mais ça j'en doute pas
tous les Français seront derrière nous
pour les Jeux Olympiques merci ggory
boget on suivra vos performances avec
attention à ro l'année prochaine on
passe maintenant au
handisport les Jeux paralympiques de Rio
sont programmés du 7 au 18 septembre
juste après les Jeux Olympiques au
programme de cette compétition 22
épreuves il y aura notamment du golf du
basketball mais également du tennis un
sport que pratique le rambolitain Johan
killyou ce jeune homme amputé d'une
jambe vise une place dans l'équipe de
France portrait de ce rambolitin au
revers atypique les images sont signées
à Paul
Degler à 18 ans il perd sa jambe droite
à la suite d'un cancer des EAU
aujourd'hui à 29 ans Laurent bolitain
Johann killou visent une première
participation au Jeu paralympique en en
tennis depuis sa première licence en
disport en 2008 son ascension est
fulgurante l'ivelinois est passé de
statut de débutant à celui de sportif de
haut niveau en moins de 10 ans pour
déstabiliser ses adversaires il a
travaillé sans répis son revers il a
également appris à maîtriser son
fauteuil de compétition pour se déplacer
sur le cours c'est un fauteuil
particulier adapté pour chaque handicap
donc moi si vu que je suis amputé d'une
jambes donc on m'a fait faire une une
coque en carbone sur mesure avec une
inclinon des roues à 20° pour pouvoir
euh bouger avec le fauteuil également
tourner à 360° c'est important et on a
un système de petites roulettes en fait
qui nous permet d'adapter le fauteuil à
chaque type de surface de terrain voilà
parce qu'on ne joue pas que sur du dur
on peut jouer sur terre batue de la
moquette tout type de terrain donc c'est
les fauteuils spécifique actuellement
numéro 7 français en simple et numéro 5
en double le tennisman s'est construit
un solide palmarès sur ces trois
dernières années en remportant notamment
l'Open du Chili et celui d'Argentine en
2014 il rêve aujourd'hui d'intégrer le
Pôle France pour une compétition
olympique c'est clair que c'est un rêve
c'est c'est une grande ambition c'est
c'est c'est un c'est un projet qu'on a
tous envie de concrétiser en quand on
est sportif valider en dis sport donc et
puis de de pouvoir partir de représenter
sa nation aussi c'est quelque chose de
grand euh oui on peut dire que c'est un
rêve donc maintenant j'ai j'aimerais
bien le le réaliser pas que le vivre
mais j'im j'aimerais le réaliser dans
quelques mois maintenant si je suis
titulaire ou remplaçant mais que on me
dit que je pars et que je représenter
l'équipe de France ce sera une grande
joie et une grande fierté Johan devra
terminer au minimum dans le top 5
français afin de réaliser son rêve pour
atteindre cet objectif le sportif
ivelinois pourrait mettre sa carrière
professionnelle entre parenthèses avant
les Jeux Olympiques j'ai continué en
fait à m'entraîner moi à peu près mes 5
6 7 heures de tennis par semaine donc au
niveau du club la clairrière j'ai une
préparation physique au niveau de la
salle Bizen à rambouiller donc le le
dirigeant m'accueille où je peux
m'entraîner 3 4 heures par semaine euh
après effectivement c'est pas suffisant
je suis en train de songer pour prendre
6 mois sabbatiques à partir de janvier
2016 jusqu'au juin 2016 pour vraiment ne
faire que ça m'entraîner quotidiennement
m'entraîner quotidiennement et faire
tous les tournois possibles pour aller
prendre les points nécessaires pour être
qualifié dans cette équipe de France
quoi les Jeux paralympiques sont
programmés du 7 au 18 septembre 2016 la
sélection française pour le tennis en
dis sport devrait être annoncé en juin
après l'andis sport coup de projectur
présent sur l'une des disciplines les
plus anciennes de des Jeux Olympiques
lesescrime la France a particulièrement
brillé dans cette compétition avec 121
médailles don 48 en or pour nous parler
donc des Jeux Olympiques et plus
particulièrement de l'escrime nous
recevons Astrid Guillard du visinet
bonsoir bonsoir alors les j c'est dans
quelques mois dans moins de dans 300
jours à peu près vous personnellement
vous sentez comment bon alors je vous
cache pas que je fais pas le décompte
pour moi les j c'est surtout aujourd'hui
de l'entraînement au quotidien pour se
préparer dans les meilleures conditions
pour déjà obtenir la qualification parce
que c'est une qualification individuelle
en concurrence avec les meilleurs
mondials et ensuite le but une fois
qu'on est qualifié c'est de revenir
médaillé donc voilà aujourd'hui je suis
pas en train de faire le décompte de se
dire que les jeux c'est dans 300 jours
je viens à l'entraînement je me
concentre et je m'entraîne au max et
justement l'entraînement ça se passe
comment vous avez une préparation
spécifique peut-être pour
l'événement pour pour préparer
l'événement alors bah ça c'est un petit
peu de préparation mentale effectivement
que je fais de mon côté euh l'idée c'est
de pouvoir se concentrer et de pas
penser à l'enjeu en fait de rester dans
le plaisir dans le jeu de l'escrim sans
être complètement paralysé par l'enjeu
de l'événement c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
pas penser au conséquences il faut pas
passer aux expériences du passé faut
être dans l'instant présent et c'est
comme ça qu'on peut s'exprimer et avec
vos partenaires ça se passe comment
justement c'est ces séances
d'entraînement c'est peut-être plus
rugueux c'est il y a plus de contact
plus de détermination ou c'est des
entraîn ement comme d'habitude il y a
plus de concentration il y a plus
d'envie plus de détermination ça veut
dire que les assauts sont sont plus
rudes mais je trouve que c'est une bonne
chose parce qu'après quand on arrive en
compétition vos adversaires quand il y a
des Russes en face de vous elles vous
font pas de cadeau donc c'est important
de répéter à l'entraînement des
situations qui sont réalistes par
rapport à ce qu'on va rencontrer en
compétition vous avez participé à
plusieurs grandes compétitions ces
derniers mois quelle est la compétition
qui vous a demandé le plus d'effort
peut-être celle qui m'a demandé le plus
d'effort je crois que ça doit être les
championnats du monde cette année parce
que c'était une épreuve importante pour
la qualification au Jeux Olympiques qui
a commencé il y a quelques mois
maintenant euh il y avait la compétition
individuelle et par équipe l'individuel
ça s'est pas passé comme je le voulais
donc c'est vrai que il a fallu se
remobiliser se reconcentrer pour le par
équipe et voilà je pense que celle-ci ça
m'a vraiment demandé parce qu'il y avait
un un enjeu fort et que autant en
individuel je suis un petit peu passée à
côté autant pour les équipes bah voilà
j'ai su remettre en place que je sais
faire mon escrime pour pouvoir obtenir
cette belle médaille de bronze et
comment jugez-vous le niveau de
l'escrime en France on sait qu'au
dernier Joo ça a pas été totalement ça
il y a eu un zéro pointé le premier
depuis les Jeux de Rome dans les années
60 est-ce que vous pensez que l'escrime
peut rebondir à nouveau sur ses
prochains Jeux Olympique au Brésil j'ai
envie de vous dire que l'escrime a déjà
rebondi il n'y a qu'à regarder les
résultats en championnat d'Europe en
Championnat du Monde ou en Coupe du
Monde tout au long des saisons on
revient à chaque fois médaillé moi avec
le fleur et dame je suis depuis les Jeux
de Londres systématiquement médaillé en
grand championnat je pense que ça c'est
un signal fort ça veut dire qu'il y a un
collectif qui est homogène déterminé et
qui arrive à faire des performances sur
des grands événements donc après à nous
de garder ça jusqu'aux Jeux Olympiques
et justement de pas être inhibé parce
que il y a eu un zéro pointé à longes
parce que c'est un grand événement je
pense que ce sera important justement
d'avoir tout un travail d'accompagnement
sur la préparation d'un grand événement
donc vous ne rassurez il n'y aura pas de
zé pointé au prochains jeux olympiques
vous pouvez toujours aller voir un
médium mais moi je sens ce qui se passe
ici à linep je sens les athlètes que ce
soit dans les trois armes le sable
fleuret ou l'épée et et je sens qu'il
est en train de se passer quelque chose
et que c'est certainement pas du tout la
même dynamique que celle qu'il y avait
avant Londres et quelles sont les
erreurs justement qu'il ne faudra
peut-être pas reproduire alors c'est on
a déjà modifié des choses depuis Londres
notamment la mixité vous l'avez vu là on
s'entraîne avec les garçons donc là
c'est une excellente émulation puisque
ça nous fait des adversaires qui sont
plus physiques ça nous oblige à aller
chercher des ressources donc ça c'est
excellent pour nous préparer pour des
grandes compétitions et puis ensuite on
a mis aussi en place un préparateur
physique qui nous accompagne pour la
préparation et aujourd'hui le sport
moderne n'est pas sans préparateur
physique sans l'aspect de la préparation
physique et de la musculation donc
c'était deux éléments je pense qui
étaient à corriger à moindre frais et
c'est ce qui a été fait et est-ce que
vous craignez certaines nations quelles
sont les nations favorites pour ces jeux
en escrime en escrime l'Italie reste
reine malheureusement notamment au
Fleuré qui est mon arme donc je dirais
italie-russie je mettrai la France en 3è
position néanmoins et puis les
États-Unis qui poussent fort avec la
Corée et vous personnellement dans ces
jeux vous voulez quoi et bien j'ai déjà
fait les Jeux Olympiques de Londres je
suis revenue sans médaille donc si je
vais à Rio c'est pour revenir avec
quelque chose merci beaucoup asrid
Guyard et maintenant on passe au
golf nous avons changé le décor pour
cette émission spéciale Jeux Olympiques
nous sommes désormais au Golf National
de
50 an en Eveline la structure pourrait
accueillir les Jeux olympiques 2024 si
la candidature de la France est retenue
par le Comité international olympique le
golf va réintégrer les Jeux Olympiques
l'année prochaine à Rio après avoir été
retiré du programme en 1904 j'ai pu
tester ce sport à en
[Musique]
cours le golf est le sport individuel le
plus pratiqué au monde avec 82 millions
de licenciers ce sport a été créé en
Écosse à saint-androus aujourd'hui cette
discipline va être réintégrée aux Jeux
olympiques de 2016 et s professionnalisé
nous allons rencontrer Vincent cousin
responsableenseignement au Golf National
de guancour pour qu'il me
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
coache bonjour vcent bonjour ça va bien
ça va bien ça va bien bonne route oui
bonne route ça va j'ai pas été très loin
bon très bien écoute en attendant j'ai
préparé les situations ok on va
commencer par un petit peu de peting ça
c'est on commence tranquillement c'est
trquement le peting est temps de mettre
la balle dans le trou faire rouler la
balle sur le gre à la suite de ça on ira
au practice voir le swing taper les
balles se défouler ti le plus loin
possible ça exactement ti le plus loin
possible et si tu as été un bon élève je
te propose d'après que on se fasse un
petit défi on joue numéro tous les deux
l'un contre l'autre sera le trou numéro
1 de lois d'accord ça comm je par
perdant pour l'instant du coup pour
it il aura chacun à
faire regarde on va faire extrêmement
simple je te mets une
balle et pour commencer c'est ta C c'est
ce Peet drapeau tu tiens le CL comme tu
veux la main gauch généralement ha
surob trouver un mouvement de
balancier avec une certaine symétrie et
de la douceur parce faut que tu
t'habitudes à la
vitesse
[Musique]
c'est pas mal pas tout à fait ça tout
fait ça pour une première c'est bien
après encore une fois le dosage c'est
des choses qui vont rentrer
tranquillement dans tes sensations en
répétant et en trouvant le mais c'est
vra qu'on voit que ça va quand même
assez vite ça va ass
[Musique]
vite
ben voilà c'est dans la caisse très
bien alors c'est extrêmement
simple dans un premier temps tu
t'organis devant la
B alors niveau des mains par contre du
coup on place comment main gauche en
ha
droite exa P vett le club voilà on va
faire relativement simple faut faire
assz assez basique parce que le but du
jeu c'est quand même que tu as forcément
quelque
chose qui va ressortir du tout ça allez
t'installes plus dépou et au fur et à
mesure on va je vais t'aider à à essayer
de faire avancer la B
ok forcément
[Musique]
forcément
c'est pas mal pas mal bien bon ben je
crois que je suis prêt pour pour aller
sur le terrain ah je pense que c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
possibleer je propose de le faire ton
objectif c'est faire en 5 coups en coup
c'est réalisable pour Mo coup c'est
réalisable
et moi pour que ça soit à peu près même
pas à peu près mais soit respecté il
faut que je fasse en TR ça marche voilà
le TR est disponible on y va allez les
hommes il partent des Bou
[Musique]
jaunes tu as V le drapeau le drapeau ok
bien j
va
alors c'est parfait je la vois même
[Musique]
pas B pas mal aussi
he c'est difficile c'est comme c'est
difficile ou oui tu sais pas débrouiller
c'est
[Musique]
difficile
un peu trop fort un pe
attaquer c'est très bien joué très bien
joué
bien
égalité je suis bien sorti bravo bravo
joué
coup de projecteur à présent sur les
ivelinois qui devrai partir l'année
prochaine aux Jeux olympiques de Rio
tout d'abord devrait y avoir les joueuse
de l'équipe de France de football qui
joue au pariss-germain Lord boulot et
Marie lordordelli Lord boulot qui joue
au poste de latéral gauche elle a
disputé plus de 190 matchs avec le PSG
depuis 2005 et compte 62 sélections avec
les Bleus Marie lordelli joue quant à
elle en attaque elle est passé par
Montpellier avant de revenir au PSG en
2013 elle a marqué 49 buts en 52 matchs
en 2 ans elle compte 90 sélection et 61
buts avec les Bleus au niveau du
cyclisme on ne l'a pas mentionné tout à
l'heure Sandy cler devrait être du
voyage également à Rio la sprinteuse de
27 ans espère accrocher des médailles au
jeu elle a été championne d'Europe de
vitesse en 2010 en cyclisme également
mais cette fois-ci chez les hommes lign
Montin François Perville espère
décrocher à 30 ans l'or olympique après
avoir emporté CIN titres de champion du
monde sur les deux derniers Mondiaux il
devrait au minimum ramener une médaille
pendant la compétition enfin en aviron
le versaill et Thomas Barou devrait
prendre l'avion avec l'équipe de France
il vient d'ailleurs de remporter une
médaille de bronze lors des derniers
championnats du monde organisé à agbet
en savoir en 400 barreur po léger il
devrait miser une médaille au je c'est
la fin de cette émission spéciale Jeux
Olympiques merci de l'avoir suivi je
vous retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau magazine d'ici là passer une
excellente semaine sportive très belle
soirée sur TVfil
[Musique]